[Música]
três palavras fogo humanidade e
criatividade
durante milênios a humanidade esteve de
um lado e o fogo de outro
foi preciso a criatividade para o news
imagine a milhares de anos atrás os
gomos erectus os nossos ancestrais
observando um tronco de árvore
incendiado por um raio
eles observam as chamas mas não as
entendem
certamente algum deles pegou um graveto
encostou na chama tentou fazer uma tocha
achando que a chama eterna mas não era
talvez alguns dos homo erectus tem
também tentado espantar o fogo com
gritos mas a criatividade
essa espécie de energia que gera idéias
surpreendentes fez dos homo erectus os
primeiros a dominarem o fogo
primeiro eles tentaram com a fricção de
pedras
depois com a fricção de madeiras e os
homo erectus até conseguiram desenvolver
um pequeno aratu que encostando numa
pedra produzir a faísca com a faísca
eles tinham o fogo com fogo e explodiu
mas a sua carne de caça e espantar os
animais selvagens que chegavam perto
deles criatividade idéias idéias gente
são apenas idéias são como uma chama que
pode se apagar em qualquer momento basta
uma sopro para as que as idéias funcione
elas precisam ser aplicadas testadas
sistematizadas eu vou contar uma
história aqui uma história bem pessoal
que eu nunca contei
então é a primeira vez que eu vou contar
pra vocês é como eu cheguei aqui em
jaraguá do sul e
como eu criei um sistema literário
dentro da cidade de jaraguá do sul nos
anos 2000 a minha namorada veio
trabalhar aqui numa grande empresa uma
assessoria de comunicação e eu pra
testar novos ares
acabei vindo junto com a cheguei aqui na
cidade já tinha alguns livros publicados
tinha uma ampla noção do mercado
editorial brasileiro já tinha feito
diversos cursos e não consegui me
recolocar no mercado de trabalho
então primeiro trabalhei como vendedor
de anúncios publicitários no jornal
local
o jornal já até já faliu talvez eu tenha
contribuído para isso claro e depois eu
trabalhei no calçadão aqui da cidade
como vendedor de termos uma loja aqui do
calçadão
mas desde o momento que eu pisei na
cidade eu tinha uma idéia uma chama que
eu queria testar ver se ela iria se a
pagar ou não ea idéia era o que criar um
sistema literário dentro da cidade
bom como eu estava em jaraguá do sul e
as coisas acontecendo no mundo no brasil
eventos de literatura cursos
eu pensei o seguinte se eu não posso ir
até à montanha vou tentar aproximar a
montanha na traseira montanha até mim
então no ano de 2003
eu pedi demissão da loja que eu
trabalhava de roupas e com a rescisão e
um computador emprestado da minha
namorada que na época era um toshiba com
20 gb de memória eu fundei em 2003
a design editora que foi a primeira
editora profissional aqui da cidade de
jaraguá do sul a primeira editora a
pensar o livro não apenas como um objeto
mas como um conector entre pessoas
a design editora que na verdade poderia
chamar de e auditora porque eu fazia
tudo né então eu criava capa eu
diagramava o livro eu fazia a revisão do
livro que mais organizava o lançamento
eu planejava a estratégia de marketing
do livro a design editora começou a
publicar os autores locais e eu pensei
bom se eu quero ter um sistema literário
botando na cidade
o ter os passos seguintes e
estrategicamente fui pro outro passo
qual era o outro passo é preparar e
formar os escritores locais nós em
parceria com outras entidades
criamos uma série de oficinas gratuitas
de escrita criativa aqui na cidade
então para quê para dar um cabedal de
referência de escritores locais
nós todos nós somos a soma das nossas
referências é tudo aquilo que a gente
ouve tudo aquilo que a gente escuta tudo
aquilo que aquilo que a gente vê
acabamos formando enquanto indivíduos
então essa série de oficinas foi
justamente para preparar esses autores e
também dá um start criativo neles porque
o que acontece quando você está
começando a escrever um livro quando se
está começando a se entender enquanto
escritor
qual é o principal erro qual é o grande
erro é escrever como gostaria e não como
realmente escreve ou seja o escritor
iniciante emula o ideal descrita a
escrever como clarice escrever como
machado ele acaba emulando esse ideal de
escrita e esquece que ele tem uma voz
própria uma digital muito própria que é
digital dele essa voz criativa e é para
isso que servem as oficinas criativas
além de escrita criativa além de dar o
cabedal de referências
vamos tentar devolver a singularidade de
cada autor
e qual foi o segundo passo
essa é a criação desse sistema nós
criamos o círculo de leitura de jaraguá
do sul
lá em 2005 se não me engano não é o que
era o círculo eleitoral de jaraguá do
sul era um encontro ficávamos todos em
círculos onde cada um falava sobre o
livro que estava lendo e qual sua
experiência que tinha qualquer livro e o
encontro também tinha o que tinha sempre
um convidado que vinha de fora para
passar as suas impressões não era um
escritor famoso ou era é um professor e
uma coisa muito bacana era qual que as
pessoas ficavam em círculo isso nos
remetia à cena ancestral da leitura
qualquer cenas extra da leitura as
pessoas ficavam redor da fogueira das
fogueiras contando histórias
essas histórias que vinham de geração em
geração de geração em geração
então novos reconecta vamos com a nossa
própria ancestralidade tínhamos uma
editora que foi um passo importante para
a cidade
você sabe o que faz um editor o editor é
um mediador de conhecimento
o livro durante muitos séculos foi o
grande transmissor de conhecimento
século a século foi a única mídia de
transmissão de conhecimento hoje nós
temos um rádio a internet é o cinema
mas durante séculos todo o conhecimento
é cultural e conhecimento estético
conhecimento tecnológico foi transmitido
através do livro esse grande e primeiro
amigo da humanidade 2004 2005 começamos
a preparar o grande pulo
porque se nós quiséssemos ter um sistema
literário dentro da cidade
temos editora temos os leitores
preparados temos os escritores nós
precisávamos o quê conectará comunidade
precisávamos de uma ação dentro desse
sistema literário que conectasse toda a
comunidade e desce um ganho que não
fosse apenas um ganho financeiro real
que fosse também um ganho simbólico
conexão essa é a palavra então nós
criamos
depois de estudar no ano de 2004 2005 e
a feira do livro de jaraguá do sul que
foi um grande passo para fechar essa
cadeia produtiva do livro esse sistema
literário como pensamos a feira do livro
não apenas como um comércio de livros de
maneira alguma
sempre como um palco de idéias um palco
de integração que maneira
trazer as pessoas para o evento
trabalhar um sistema que fosse de fora
para dentro e hoje a feira do livro é
que nesse palco nesse palco da scar né
então com a idéia da feira do livro
memorial formar leitores a médio e longo
prazo
eu coordenei as nove primeiras edições
da feira
sempre com um objetivo muito claro
formar leitores a médio longo prazo e
também trazer conexões conexões
diferentes a comunidade de que maneira
trouxemos grandes nomes da cultura
brasileira para jaraguá do sul
maurício de sousa ziraldo adriana
calcanhotto é talvez o que mais aqui de
cabeça que gregório duviver uma série de
nomes que vieram trocar com a cidade
mas trocar de verdade mas a grande troca
foi com os alunos todos os anos centenas
de alunos vem gratuitamente com ônibus
escolares através de parcerias com
diversas instituições porque a feira é o
resultado da parceria com diversas
instituições do município
todos os anos centenas de crianças vêm
gratuitamente através de um corredor de
livros e após atravessar esse corredor
de livros podem se deparar com
espetáculos de dança teatro música e com
grandes debates da literatura então ok
implantamos um sistema criativo sistema
literário na cidade
sim ele funciona sim porque os
escritores conseguem produzir e
conseguem fazer o seu produto circular e
conseguem se conectar com os leitores
certo
aí eu me faço uma pergunta uma pergunta
que eu faço pra todos vocês aqui além de
fazer pra mim eu faço pra vocês se
conseguimos implantar um sistema
literário na cidade o sistema literário
em jaraguá do sul
conseguimos implantar um sistema
criativo
sim não assim não
sim não sei por que eu não sei
para implantar o sistema criativo nós
queremos ter a mínima noção da
representatividade da economia criativa
aqui no município
a economia criativa movimenta bilhões no
mundo inteiro o que a economia criativa
a economia criativa é a união dos
setores que dependem do que
a criatividade e da propriedade
intelectual arquitetura moda design
artesanato gastronomia uma série de
setores que não estão de nenhuma maneira
conectados aqui na cidade de jaraguá do
sul
não há nenhuma conversa no anão bloco
então hoje não conseguimos implantar um
sistema criativa mas a longo prazo
sim conseguiremos porque nós
precisaremos saber o impacto da economia
criativa no município de jaraguá do sul
enquanto que ela tende rendimento
quantas pessoas
ela atinge qual é a verdadeira matriz
econômica criativa da cidade de jaraguá
do sul
gente é incabível isso uma cidade
inovadora como jaraguá do sul não tem
implantado no sistema de economia
criativa
não há conexão nenhuma pensar
o artesão não se conecta com o
distribuidor quando os arquitetos nós
temos na cidade enquanto os designers
então é um mercado que está totalmente
pulverizado e não há um contato nós não
temos um estudo não temos um preparo pra
implantar isso então eu digo o seguinte
quero lançar aqui uma provocação pra
vocês né é uma palavra uma fase na
verdade uma frase que eu vou jogar com
uma frase no futuro talvez essa frase
sai voando vai se conectar com alguma
nuvem vai chover que a frase vai ficar
por aqui tá
somos uma cidade criativa não sabemos
podemos ser sim
jaraguá do sul cidade criativa tá essa
frase foi a chegar na nuvem
vai chover é o momento para se pensar
nisso
de que maneira construir essa
conectividade de que maneira
nós podemos nos conectar de que maneira
nós podemos transformar a cidade
a pergunta primordial a pergunta
principal se sabe qual é
não é o que eu posso ganhar com isso no
momento no início é o que eu posso
oferecer pra que isso revele se realize
porque se nós tivermos um sistema de
economia criativa encantado na cidade
nós podemos deixar um legado simbólico
para a cidade algo de longo prazo
a feira do livro de jaraguá do sul é uma
chama que não se apaga está acesa há
mais de dez anos
certo se há 25 anos atrás alguém
dissesse olha jaraguá do sul vai ter um
evento que será um dos mais
referenciados grandes referências do sul
do brasil ninguém acreditaria
então por isso disseram hoje jaraguá do
sul cidade criativa
talvez as pessoas não acreditem mas a
idéia foi para a nuvem foi para uma
coletividade
por isso uma chama gente é só uma chama
é só uma idéia ela pode se apagar
agora muitas chamas
muitas luzes qualquer chama
contemporânea onde você sabe a luz do
celular certo vamos ligar o celular uma
chama só não conecta aí vamos lá todo
mundo com a luzinha do celular
vamos lá não é mais só uma chama na são
várias as chamas
isso aí
precisamos de idéias que nos conecta
precisamos de idéias que transformem a
cidade
a nossa cidade de jaraguá do sul a
cidade criativa três palavras rubro
humanidade criatividade
obrigado
[Música]